Христос народився пане голова шановне
президент Шановні колеги Україна
Європейська держава і цей свідомий вибір
ми зробили
2014 року в повній мірі і тому наше
Захисники зараз несуть на таку
найкривавішу не жорстокішою найдорожчу
ціну за те щоб ми стали частиною
Європейського Союзу і частиною НАТО але
ми відбиваємо цю російську агресію а
задля захисту європейських цінностей
свободи і демократії і адаптація
українського законодавства до норм
європейського та ратифікація різних
конвенцій вони надзвичайно важливі Тому
наша фракція європейської солідарності
буде їх підтримувати але набагато
важливіше все ж таки працювати за
цивілізованими європейськими правилами
підтверджуючи власну дорослість і
готовність до членства в єсенато На жаль
вчора під час засідання комітету
закордонних справ став це такий
прецедент який ганьбить парламенту
України коли коміте скасував власне
рішення грудневе рішення про включення
Петра Порошенка до складу постійної
делегації в парі лідери опозиції з
дипломатичним досвідом широкою мережею
міжнародних контактів його усунули від
участі в делегації надаючи жодного
адекватного чоловічного пояснення отак
виглядає Єдність і я розумію що на жаль
мій виступ не покажуть по єдиному
марафону Ми також пам'ятаємо як
Порошенко не пускали з країни на
засідання парламентської асамблеї НАТО і
це дрібне рішення вчорашнє воно не
демонструє дії як Європейського
парламенту тому я би закликала і
зверталась до голови Верховної Ради щоб
він дав доручення скликати негайно знову
комітет і розглянути це питання все ж
таки без маніпуляцій керуватися
ефективністю і результатом задля
інтересів України тому що наша команда
як працювала спільно з державними
інституціями неурядовим сектором на
дипломатичному фронті так і буде далі
працювати задля Перемоги України Дякую і
слава Україні